uh this one you may have seen coming
this is like a big one because this is
like a series of dominoes August 1st
okay uh in DC yeah a Federal grand jury
indicted president Trump over alleged
efforts to overturn the election I'm
shocked and appalled
yeah yeah are you sure all right no
another one of these things you know
when I when I went off the grid last
year was the Mar-A-Lago raid and then
when I came back actually in Larry Elder
was the was the guest host the mar-lago
raid I think was like the first week of
August right and then I came back he
tells me about the whole thing and I was
like you know nothing's gonna happen
with this like well maybe so what what's
going on now another indictments we're
going to do this in chronological order
yeah okay so that was a kind of a very
big one um and this is in DC and
obviously with the DC jury it's going to
be very tough for any Republican who's
President Trump so he's got the federal
case he's now got the decent case the
New York okay this is the big one
Trump and 18 others
were indicted in Georgia oh so the
Georgia thing yeah including Rico
charges part of this let me read you
about the names of the 19 people okay uh
some of them are not our names I don't
know one so president Trump who is going
to be arrested I'm not joking he's going
to be arrested Thursday in Georgia
they are actually saying he's going to
be arrested I'm going down to Georgia to
surrender on Thursday he is going to be
arrested okay there's questions
what's next season yeah we got others
John Eastman his attorney okay here's
the other thing as Chris Christie knows
very well I'm not I'm not being glib
here these prosecutors know if they get
your lawyer to flip that's really really
bad yeah because your lawyer
attorney-client privilege is sacrosanct
and American law usually yeah you tell
your lawyer what you did or like Hey how
do we work around this they've got the
goods so they flipped John Eastman he's
being charged wait sorry one question
what's the date on this where are we at
chronologically because now I'm sort of
amazed
the charges went down on August 14th
okay so going to Georgia this week to
turn themselves in and be arrested
Johnny Smith is one of them here's a
name that you're gonna be very familiar
to you mark Meadows you just ran into
his brother I ran into his brother at
the airport yesterday so Mark I didn't
talk to him I know nothing he just said
he likes the show
Forest
yeah in Atlanta she's the former Chief
of Staff here's another name Sydney
Powell
Rudy uh so my position is they've been
at it for Rudy for a long time because
he proved that you don't have to have
high crime rates in poverty in these
cities New York was considered
uncomfortable he showed that when you
have these out of control cities you
guys want this because by Design and
they've never forgiven him for it all
right so who else is in this thing um so
basically what the idea though is that
they want to get all these people to
flip on Trump like that well not only
that so apparently Rudy's been flipping
they've been pointing the finger at
Sydney Powell because the Rudy approach
to 2020 it was very different from the
Sydney Powell approach so there's been a
lot of finger and this happens all the
time with Rico charges you get everyone
together and everyone just starts
turning the finger I'm sorry pointing
the thing with each other and you can't
blame them yeah it's like it's like why
am I going down with the ship when this
lunatic did the crime when I didn't do
anything I rented a room five other
lawyers I'm gonna go through their names
they're not familiar to me for them
Jeffrey Clark I was not familiar with
him Kenneth cheese bro uh Ray Smith
Robert Chesney and here's someone that
you are quite familiar with a certain
Jenna Ellis
wasn't she the one who went after you
publicly yeah she went after me publicly
when we announced we were having kids
but she actually personally apologized
to me yeah that's good to know yeah and
I accepted her apology and we're good on
that I can't speak to the her legal
expertise or that sort of thing David
Shaffer who's former chairman of the GOP
yeah a Georgia state senator Sean still
and three other names and of course
president Trump is the 19th uh person
and he's looking at uh I think it's
something like 700 years with all these
charges
I mean doesn't it seem to you that
they're just going to keep I don't know
if there's anything else still in the
docket because it seemed like Georgia
was the big one but okay so a DC one I
missed on August 1st now you're telling
me the George one which we knew was
coming but haven't they already said
that the first the trial for the federal
case isn't it in it's next April or
something or they wanted so it's like
right before super Tuesday it's like
they want all of this to make
everyone crazy